corner with a plock moved into the cornerback
and in front trying to find Rodriguez and rard
was there as well here comes a break for S
his inot subb and he put it in behind MOSI
watch the timing of the pass here from Hegel it
is brilliant then stammer gets the shot that he
wants MOSI is way out stammer has the presence
of mine on this rebound here he just a little
how does that not go in on the rebound he had
the presence of mind to get a piece of that one
too and shot GL Denning with a wicked wrer that
just missed here's Stan Coast again fans on that
one and Florida one on home I against Vegas in
the first rematch of last year's standa final
there's a w around attempt and a turnover for
behind the net by Matthew kachu backto back 30
goal seasons for him now in comes Evan Rodriguez
reagent signing by the Panthers one back to the
point for forsley forsing moves it across they
score a shot from the point Finds Its way in it
was eblad with the shot and it looks like it is
going to be his goal one- nothing Panthers last
several years and E blad's always been leading the
way this is a nasty redirection watch vasileski
it just gets knocked out of the air that go off
a chernack stick I guess it must have I wasn't
sure who had knocked it but look at the change
of Direction Vass completely full headman up top
near side for COV COV pull back and forth with COV
up top again here St goes with a shot and barosi
shifted to meet the stop over the last couple
of Seasons coocher off to Hond Hond that kind
of shovels it ahead again he's a lefty that has
to Pivot a little bit and get it over to stammer
as quick as he can stammer got a huge wheelhouse
but for Victor he has to get it there as quickly
as possible to give him a chance COV with a
good shot nice save by bski as he flashed out
that right pad on a quick onetime by COV COV
will move out high like that sometimes here
he is from the corner yeah we've seen him score
from that spot this season stamp go back to CRA
into the middle for point oh what a save by mski
beautiful pass here by Stam Coast with two guys
on him Crosslines pass to one touch the here's be
again his shot looking for a tip and it's got down
by kachuck ends up back in the line mon the r shot
right therei makes a great stop right in front on
forgy Ren picks it up there's LEL with
a shot did that hit the post I think it
did as it car's up and on of play either the
post or vaselin stick either way it stays one
nothing here's barov for in the lightning to
go out and make a play of that puck that's Les
he knocked it into the corner SLE back and
out of the reach of Evan Rodriguez foring
to Rodriguez Reinhardt on his backand barkov
to Rodriguez centers it they score it comes
right to Reinhard and he is not missing much
these days two nothing Panthers I said about
for heggy they just score they just quietly go
about their business they get into the scoring
areas at the right time and they're playing
with guys with Talent how about that with
a little backhand pass there and Reinhardt is
just in behind everybody there he is he's just
kind of cruising along Celli comes back to
help he's in front of the net lightning have
B bed up ahead now it's selli selli steps in Bull
with SC gets it back to selli and they got a shot
away and a broken Rush braasi with a save another
shot goes high and one gock goinging to split the
D there he's tangle up with that Larson they're
both in the net meantime back to the way Rodriguez
drops it off out in front and second attempt
there by barov another stretch pass CRA at the
line Le for perix perix takes the puck wide on
Benn bck back across the grave then he gets it
right back as it back to him now headen with
a shot re SC Nikita coov the 300th goal of his
career D getting involved perix gets up on the
play Hond gets up on the play here Comes perix
take the puck deep get it into the middle it's a
good keep up with the blue line as well and this
was key Hedman just gets it back towards the night
the net excuse me Paul gets a a stick on it and
then kucherov going the opposite direction is able
to put it underneath boski for his first mistake
29 seconds to go on the lightning power play Bea
hard off the fors knocked down momentarily there
by poov marov trying to get away there now it's
Reinhard he's in Reinhard scores a shorthanded
goal by Sam Reinhardt restored was the two goal
lead I mean he he does a real good job along
here watch headman headman just making sure okay
you're not going to get to the front of the net
but he lost position a little bit when Hedman lost
body position he allowed Reinhardt to get inside
him H's there but when Hy stops skating and looks
down to try to fish for the puck that's where he
was done for Reinhardt in a forward situation
like this if everything goes right you get a
chance third short headed goal out this season and
that one is a real killer what a turn of events
as the power play is about to expire here's
aimon now asimon with a shot start hey Mikey
32 bills nice job by aimont here he's a lefty
on the rightwing side stays with it that's what
fooled m but brosi lost his rhythm on the shot
see he's down he's just getting up and so he
lost his positioning just by a tag as lifted back
out by the Panthers back up to selli selli CS back
L man Off the Bench is De hor dear is shoots
and fori got a piece of that stepping up his
turn reard makes the play and gets it up pass
up ahead to barov barov is in hits the post oh
man what a break for the liting a spectacular
move by barov and he rattled it off the IR on
the D Man and you're not going to get it back
from him beautiful move he has vasileski frozen
you can see vasy was leaning down into his right
markov's going to go back in the other direction
vasy always gets it look at vasileski legs oh
my goodness we've reached the Midway point of
this third period lightning have scored a couple
oneg goal gain here's kachu and for Veri his shot
block now egad with a drive that's blocked
by perit quickly pass report point is in Bur
is Bo oh what a stop by bosski unbelievable
so he thought but Broski gets him with the
glove back and forth he goes with barov Markov
again at the top of the circle P it down low o
for sa baseski rebound picked up by fori now
it's barov again Sasha barov he'll put it up
top with a snap shot TI rebound right there
was good shot more pressure V with a drive
save oh what a stop by VY near side as he RS
for haggy barkov again Florida just grinding
away the clock here's Bley his shot and it
goes just wide on again walks out senters
it across and vasileski with one more stop as
we hit the horn and in career game behind the
bench number 1,800 Paul Maurice and the
Florida Panthers win this one 32 final